el opositor leopoldo lópez miembro del
partido voluntad popular salió de
venezuela este viernes y muy pronto
estará en españa según aseguró su padre
fuentes de la oposición señalan que ha
viajado a colombia el ministerio de
relaciones exteriores de españa confirmó
que lópez abandonó por decisión
voluntaria y personal la residencia del
embajador en venezuela donde se
encontraba en calidad de huésped desde
el pasado 30 de abril de 2019 el líder
de la oposición juan guaidó que salió de
las filas del partido voluntad popular
expresó a través de las redes sociales
que leopoldo lópez logró salir del país
burlando lo que él llama el aparato
represivo de nicolás maduro y que su
aporte a venezuela será desde un nuevo
espacio de acción por otra parte el
partido voluntad popular emitió un
comunicado donde confirma que su líder
saluda a territorio internacional para
impulsar nuevas acciones en la lucha por
la libertad y que le manifiestan todo su
apoyo asimismo enfatiza el comunicado
que seguirán respaldando la unidad y la
ruta establecida por juan guaidó en la
consulta popular la no participación del
fraude
de diciembre y la protección
internacional al pueblo frente a los
crímenes de lesa humanidad también
dieron a conocer que leopoldo lópez se
comunicará muy pronto con el país